thank you good afternoon councillors and
staff welcome to the extraordinary
meeting of the caricature city council
of may 2020
too
we have it do we have any apologies
counselor kit and mrs cooper
thank you
secondly just
moved and seconded it put it to the boat
all in favor say aye aye
against carried
declaration of interest any changes
there
no not
but i'm working on
working together legacy report
it's
[Music]
thank you in fact uh thanks to tim
actually jane leads off today and i'll
follow up in this case which is probably
the better order
thank you your worship councillors
look what you've got in front of you is
a small covering report with a great big
agenda
which contains the final legacy report
this report
describes how we took ownership of our
own problems
what we did about them and what were the
outcomes and the learnings
it's got four audiences uh the residents
and people of invercargill
the potential either sitting candidates
or new candidates for council next year
the department of internal affairs and
finally the wider local government
sector and they'll all have different
sections that they'll be interested in
it can be read as a standalone document
so you can read the whole thing but also
if you read the executive summary the
short version covers
everything
it covers a period from about mid 2020
until now
and finally just in introducing the
report it reflects your own feedback as
well as the outcomes of all our various
reviews
and the local government the local
resident survey
i'm going to start at the
conclusion and sort of one sentence
because it's a notable sentence
that invercargill city council is now in
a good position to push ahead on its own
without the support of our working on
working together program
sorry what was that that's all right you
worship and
here we are
just keep going
this is an important finding
it acknowledges the work that
everybody's put into focus on the issues
and find a way forward
and it also recognizes the importance of
the new processes policies
and the working ethos of council itself
but there is about it comes with some
words of caution
and that is
that the momentum isn't lost
there's an ongoing job for the council
to do
and to focus on how it operates build on
the good work to date
and prevent present a professional
governance face to the community and
stakeholders
so i've just picked out a
few other things to note before i hand
over to bruce so just a quick recap
of how we got here
we got a letter from dia in august 2020
which was the catalyst for action
between august and december 2020 council
spent a great deal of time getting to
the bottom of what its problems were
and sorting out a way forward
this was resolved in november 2020
and the strategy was called working on
working together
it's been deployed over the last 18
months or so
the linchpin of the strategy
was the support provided through the
appointment of the two eas
the other
important components for the development
of the council charter
the work that the deputy mayor did and
the role he played
and a concerted effort by council on
communications
and regular reporting measuring and
monitoring both to the governance group
and risk and assurance kept us on track
the key learnings are set out in the
report but i'll just quickly
whip through the ones for council itself
govern what good governance looks like
a well-developed understanding of the
interface between governance and
management
how a strong relationship between elt
and council itself should function
the importance of the soft skills the
how is as important as the what
the need for a proactive approach to
communications in the media
and the importance of developing a good
relationship with dia
and there's a list in there
of the learnings from a sector
perspective
when we started out
we
set out five outcomes to aspire to then
added another two
we think we delivered on five
the council functioning as a governing
governing body
counselors having an understanding of
their role
counselors having capacity and
capability and knowledge to make
decisions effectively
counselors working effectively with the
chief executive and elt
and a lasting legacy which is what we
think we've got in front of us
some progress has been made in the
remaining two but there's still work to
do
there around leadership the mayor deputy
mayor and committee chairs are able to
provide leadership to others and the
council organisation
and establishing a reputation as a high
performing council
recent reviews by councillors concluded
among other things
that there's a majority of elected
members who have a clear sense of gains
made but with a slowing in momentum
the responses to the resident survey
indicate
that in the eyes of the community
there's still work to be done to improve
the governance of council and to
transform it into a high-performing
council
however
we can confidently say we have a firm
grip of the issues and a solid stake in
the ground to build upon
the ea's own feedback notes are
reproduced in the
report itself they cover the importance
of self-help
commitment to change
but this also acknowledge the value of
outside support
that's all i want to say about the
legacy report itself it takes us back to
the emphasis in the covering report that
the next step is to acknowledge the work
achieved under working and working
together
and commit to its continued
implementation of the program's
objectives over the remainder of the
triennium
and as an investment in the new council
so finally from me
this is a pgj a project governance group
group recommendation
that they endorse that you endorse the
legacy report
respond to dias later of august 2020 and
ask them for a reply
transfer
the residual monitoring functions that
is on outcomes and risks to risk
insurance
and conclude the ea's work at the end of
may and it also that will conclude the
pgg's work
and i think with these few words
hopefully not too long pass over to
bruce
thank you and and um so term i speak
today in my role primarily as the
independent advisor which you'll recall
at the stage that we got the dia letter
i was privileged that you folk appointed
me to that role to work with you
so my role really has been to book in
the total process
the first part was you will recall to
work with you to establish the problem
statements
that actually were apparent at the time
when the dia wrote to us
and perhaps a more pleasant task
was recently interviewing
all of you
to assess how we had gone
about addressing those problem issues
um
and i want to compliment you all
that over the roughly two years
you've held
that focus
and i want to acknowledge that for a
good number of you that has made a
significant change
in behavior
it has required
change
um
it's
uh gone to the extent
that in my assessment
as your adviser
i think we have what i have said in my
notes pulled back from the brink
you've actually retreated from the
precipice
and shown that you have developed skills
and capacity
expected of any group of elected members
so consequently
what i am seeing is that you're working
together
you're able to make majority decisions
which by and large you can abide by
and support
that after all is the challenge of good
leadership and governance of a council
i guess jane to some extent has given
also the challenge
and the mat the challenge is to
obviously maintain that
in the lead up to the elections
and
and to make certain that the investment
you have made
continues into the new trainium
[Music]
i think the challenge for us is
we need we i think all recognize and i
guess that's tied up with the time to
end the working on working
together program
it's time that you
collectively can demonstrate to the
community
that you can do it
and actually to the extent that i'm
chair independent chair of your
risk and insurance committee we
can do it
and also
as i have said in my wrap-up report
there will be issues between now
and the 8th of october there will be
issues after the 8th of october
it's up to us it's our choice
but i want to recognize that we do have
the soft skills to do it
so consequently i'm comfortable with
where the conclusions of the legacy
report have got to
i'm also comfortable with the report
that has come from pgg
and jane has spoken to
which amongst other things recommends
that the risk and assurance committee
the committee i chair for you
picks up
particularly monitoring the risks
that we still have to cover off and do
and as a final comment if i could just
address personally to jeff
and lindsey can i just express my
personal gratitude
for all the work you guys have done over
the two years it fell on to me
to have to ring these two guys and say
i've got a job for you
i remember actually where i was when i
rang you jeff and i think you were
thinking i might want to run a hundred
miles the other direction
i'm very glad that you didn't
lindsay you and again i remember where i
was driving when i spoke to you on the
phone
and you wondered why it needed a person
of your caliber and yet i'm very glad
that the two of you have uh have joined
the team
you've helped us
and indeed have been such an effective
part of the solution so thank you for
your input as well i know you're keen to
finish jeff 31 may and um job well done
thank you
thank you for those very kind words and
i'm sure we appreciated it very much as
members of this council
so thank you indeed
um
i've just got
five
six recommendations
and a uh
one to received a report working on
working together legacy report
endorse the
final legacy report dated 10th of may
2022
and that's attached to appendix a
that's where i've been getting into
a lot of issues
and i won't
go into them
but
i just wanted noted in the minutes that
possibly in the latency workshop
that's quite um
and
it um
i want to endorse the legacy report
that
i can't
altogether
the request of the chief executive
provide dia with a copy of the legacy
report
and record request
a response from
them for
council to consider
at its meeting of the 24th of may
2022
acknowledge the positive contribution
that the project government's group have
made
to guiding the
work
enroll
and note that their role
is now concluded
confirm
that the presidential
monitoring functions
of the working on working together
project
will become the responsibility of the
risk and assurance committee
which has been done
noting that
the four
residual risks
should be included in the council's risk
register
and acknowledge
the leadership
role
that
the ea
eas have played
and that their tenure will end
on the 31st of may 2022
and also
worship
thank you worship um two points before i
um
put forward the motion on the
recommendations that you've uh
as a chair of pug i just want to make a
brief statement
um just want to reinforce what bruce has
already said
and show some appreciation to
bruce jane
lindsey mack and jeff the input they've
had during the project um and it wasn't
just the work but it was their
availability to elect members
um as we
do business
and for some of us it's been a sounding
board um some in some cases a bit of a
mentoring role as well
um and so all four of these bring
experience that we probably didn't have
around the table to start with
so just want to thank you for that
um
in relation to the uh motions that
you've got on front of your suit
um it would be my preference to put the
motions
on a recommendation of recommendation
one
as a sole recommendation and two as a
sole recommendation that allows for the
opportunity of any member that doesn't
agree with the legacy report to say so
and then thirdly to put three through
six
as a cluster
so i'm happy to move that way
um
it should be all right because we didn't
collapse the five motion laps for one of
a second
no your worship counselor clark
intervened is councillor clark wanting
to second your motion
i don't think he's quite excuse me but i
think both councillor amanda and i raise
their hands to be the seconder
um i just need some clarity um
uh claire and any worship uh the way i
heard the
recommendations read out there was a
degree of
um
personal comment from the mayor on on
recommendation too so i'm not quite sure
what he's actually putting on that
no counsellor
uh his worship made a couple of personal
comments but that was before he what he
moved all of the recommendations and he
walked very quietly through all of the
recommendations and moved those
recommendations councillor amundsen
and councillor sopa seemed to have been
a shoot-off as to who would be the
seconder
as chair mr
chair your worship who would you like to
second the motion
i think i'd rather have it lapsed
and start again
i
are you calling for a mover of the
motion
you you have moved the motion
and you do have two elected members who
are prepared to second it
oh
okay that whatever makes it easy
so
it's been moved and seconded you're not
not yet your worship we need somebody
in the middle of your second emotions i
think one through six but i'm also happy
to take them individually um or as
counselor clark uh described
so so the most it is now a motion that
is on the floor and you may like to see
if there are any questions comments
debate of the motion
thank you
eliza moving if the first item was
to receive the report
so i guess
usually counsellors prefer to break down
and um can i seek some clarification
please
that's councillor abbott
councillor abbott
yeah i just want to seek some
clarification
um are we going to be addressing them
separately as a motion or are you moving
the entire recommendations in their
entirety that's what i want to know
after listening to councillor clark
and now listening to councillor
armistead who says she's happy to take
one and two separately that's a bit
confusing
well
let's move and see it's been
moved and segmented
your worship you were about to put the
motion that the report be received
all right
that's been moved and seconded and if
you deal with that one alone that will
allow you to open it for debate
thank you
thank you
it's been moved and seconded then
yes
yes you worship you moved it and
councillor amundsen
did it
and that is that they received a report
correct
thank you all right go to do them one at
a time
it's just that first motion at the
moment
so the first motion is to received a
report of working on working together
legacy
report it's moved and seconded
opened it up for discussion
verification
needs to be
could put the emotion if you naturally
okay
put the motion to the boat fall in favor
say aye
i am
against no
i'll have my vote against recorded
you you don't wish to receive the report
your worship
no i won't receive it as item one i'm
taking them a separate
system so this is item one and you're
voting against receiving the report
all right
that's
your worship let me intervene here um so
that we're not
creating a bit of a circus situation
here um
i
the chief executive has recommended that
you table the report
and we're voting on that that means that
you don't have to agree to a report
we're just tabling it and then we have
some ongoing discussions as we work
through recommendations two through six
i put the suggestion that we do two
separately to give you the chance to
to
vote against it if you don't agree with
the report but in doing so you still
could agree to the subsequent
recommendations around where to from
here
and so uh
um
i think that's the way forward
it sounds exactly what i was trying to
achieve
to recommendation
so i'll move recommendation to endorse
the final legacy report dated 10th of
may 2022
attached to appendix a second digital
worship
moved and seconded discussion questions
i serve counselor clients got his hand
up
oh
yeah oh sorry that was my mistake that
was the last one
uh no councillor anderson's got a hand
up
thanks um i just wanted to speak to this
because um i think it's really important
to acknowledge the process that we've
all been through here
um i think that this report and all of
the appendixes
provide some real clarity for
what's been happening this term and how
we have all worked to manage those
things
and i also think that councillors
have all benefited from
the opportunity we've had to learn from
people like lindsey mckenzie and jeff
grant but equally jane and bruce as well
um and i think that um it's
it's important to acknowledge that work
but i think that the one thing that
hasn't been acknowledged potentially is
actually all the extra work that has
been uh essentially dumped on the staff
at the invercargill city council
as a result of this process and i know
that it hasn't necessarily been a great
time for them
in some respects
but they have all worked really hard as
well and have been great support
to all of us as we've gone through this
process and i think that that's really
important to acknowledge
thank you any further
thank you worship i just want to pick up
on a point that was made by councillor
evanson and that is around the staff
when the working on working together
program started it was
an uncomfortable situation for us all to
find ourselves in but collectively we
had to move forward
one of the issues of concern that was
expressed by the department of internal
affairs was around our ability to
successfully
pull together a long-term plan
and and we did
and at a time where
councillors
were
normally busy with that ltp process we
were working additionally on top of our
own business
and the working on working together
um
and in a spotlight and and in a
spotlight that
came down to what was happening at a
governance level but could only
it could not have not had an impact on
on staff and and morel so for the fact
that they were able to pull together
an ambitious
at our direction
long-term plan
um
and put together some some really long
hours
during a time of our first ever lockdown
you know it was it was a real challenge
so
i don't think we can emphasize enough
how grateful we are to
them not only for their mahi but their
perseverance
thank you sir
discussion
thank you your worship i also want to
acknowledge the
the process um that has
taken a great deal of work and has
reached the legacy report the very good
legacy report we have here today and i
want to start by by saying the following
kota paitawati
bayakiyatata
kotapaitata
gokumal kia tina
seek out distant horizons
and value those you attain
at the start of this process where we
took ownership of our own problems as a
council
we appeared to have some very distant
horizons
and there was some doubt about how long
it would take us to attain any of those
and whether we would be in a position
position to feel that we had reached the
maturity where we would have a legacy
report in place
and a belief around the table that we
could move on
and build on the attainments we had made
i believe we are very much at that point
i believe that we do have to pay a great
deal of tribute to the council staff who
have assisted us through that process
and my colleagues have talked about that
quite clearly i also
want to thank
personally
the two excellent external advisors we
have had
you have contributed greatly to what has
happened in the last 18 months
we all know a great deal of the of the
work both in the background and the
foreground that you have put into
achieving that
we're sorry to see you go but we're also
quite proud
that we have reached a maturity point
which means that we can say
thank you
and goodbye although you are certainly
welcome back
and and i also just want to pay a little
bit of tribute to the learnings that
have formed a good part of this
this report because i think
what we have achieved as a council
um are learnings that are for ourselves
for future councils and also to be taken
note of by the wider local government
sector
and
yeah i just just didn't want the um the
vote to happen without the
acknowledgement that we have
reached a maturity point that there were
some distant horizons that looked very
very far away when we started this
process
and i think we can we can as the legacy
report acknowledges feel that there are
attainments and a platform that we have
to build on for the future for this
council and future councils thank you
thank you
better discussion questions
i'm moving along then to the request oh
sorry you wish if you're going to put
that motion
number
number two
sorry i thought we'd
put that one
to rest
um
move item two
it's been moved and seconded if you've
moved and seconded put it to the boat
all in favor say aye aye aye it's
just a point of order your worship um
are you saying no to this and you moved
it is that it's all possible
no it's
not does that work does that a double
positive negative
check standing order so there's nothing
preventing no you can't do that
through you mr chair i would say that is
perfectly
lawful acceptable for a member to move
something and vote against that it is
typical for the member to say that they
are pro-forma moving it but not
necessary so it's like ordering a pizza
having it delivered and thrown in the
red bin as long
[Laughter]
well that seems a nice sort of
conclusion
um three to six could be taken
collectively
that's three
four five and six
five and six people but they can all be
taken together they can be taken as a
block
so items three do i have to read them
out no you don't
4
5
and 6
be
together
okay put it to debate all in favor say
aye
aye aye against
harry
howard moves on to
that's the end of the agenda
oh
counselor clark has his hand up sir
council clerk
oh council o'clock
thank you just a point of clarification
from a previous um
pgg meeting which i chair at the last pg
meeting you you made a statement in
public
so the effect that
you felt uneasy because council was
suing you
and i just want to seek some
clarification like i'll have some
feedback from the community about that
um it's my understanding that the legal
case that we have between council and
yourself is actually the other way
around that you are seeking to
recover costs from us not now we're not
selling the exam it's like to clarify
that because that statement was made in
two successive meetings on the day
well i'd rather not go there
okay just just for the wrinkles in your
worship then i'll just clarify it from
my point of view
both those meetings that i attended one
of which i cheered
it's my understanding that council is
not selling you
that in fact you are certain council
thank you
thank you well i'll clear the meeting
closed thank you very much and thank you
again to our helpers it's certainly been
a trial by fire and
it's hard to put it out it's like the
wetlands really
and
it's
um i think it shows your resilience
the word they use for people in your
predicament and in mind
and we appreciate
that the fact that you've all hung in
there
to the bitter end
and
it's appreciated as well
thank you again